ROBERTS ON WHAT HAS BEEN CALLED
A NUCLEAR DEER JOHN LETTER FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
>> IT WAS A DEAR JOHN LETTER
THAT ONLY THE PRESIDENT COULD
WRITE.
ONE HOLDING THE PROMISE OF
RECONCILIATION BUT THERE IS A
THREAT TO BURN YOUR HOUSE DOWN
President: I HAVE DECIDED TO
TERMINATE THE PLAN SUMMIT IN
SINGAPORE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SITED ANGER
AND OPEN HOSTILITY IN RECENT
STATEMENTS FROM NORTH KOREAN
OFFICIALS.
President: MANY THINGS CAN
HAPPEN.
A YATE OPPORTUNITY LIES AHEAD
POTENTIALLY.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
SETBACK FOR NORTH KOREA AND
INDEED A SETBACK FOR THE WORLD.
>> WHAT KILLED THE DEAL WAS A
STATEMENT FROM THE NORTH KOREAN
KEP UTILITY FOREIGN MINISTER.
HE SAID THAT NORTH KOREAN WAS
READY FOR A NUCLEAR TO NUCLEAR
SHOWDOWN WITH THE U.S. IF TALKS
FAILED.
SHE CALLED PENCE STUPID AND A
POLITICAL DUMMY.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT MADE CLEAR,
THIS WILL ONLY END LIKE THE
LIBYA MODEL ENDED IF KIM JONG UN
DOESN'T MAKE A DEAL.
>> SOME SEE THAT AS A THREAT
UFRPLT.
>> IT'S MORE OF A FACT.
>> HE SAID, YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
NUCLEAR CAPABILITIES.
OURS OUR SO MASSIVE AND POWERFUL
I HOPE THEY NEVER HAVE TO BE
USED.
>> OUR MILITARY IS READY IF
NECESSARY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTED KIM'S
ATTITUDE HAS RECENTLY CHANGED.
>> I THINK THEY WANT TO DO WHAT
IS RIGHT.
IT WAS ONLY RECENTLY THAT HAS
TAKEN PLACE.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S
>> THE PRESIDENT WOULDN'T
EXPOUND ON WHAT HAS TAKEN PLACE
TO CHANGE NORTH KOREA'S
ATTITUDE.
HE SUGGESTED THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT GOT IT KIM'S EAR IN A
RECENT MEETING IN CHINA.
President: I THINK THERE WAS A
CHANGE IN ATTITUDE FROM KIM
YOUNG UN.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT LAID DOWN A BED
OF HIS OWN LAST NIGHT LAUNCHING
A NATIONAL SECURITY
INVESTIGATION INTO CAR AND TRUCK
IMPORTS.
THIS BROUGHT A SHARP REACTION
FROM CHINA.
>> CHINA ABUSES THE ABUSE OF THE
TERM OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT WILL SERIOUSLY DAMAGE THE
MULTI-LATERAL TRADE SYSTEM.
WE WILL SAFEGUARD OUR OWN
INTERESTS.
>> AT THE SAME TIME PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS PUTTING THE TRADE
SQUEEZE ON CHINA HE'S URNING TO
KEEP UP PRESSURE ON NORTH KOREA
TO BRING KIM TO THE TABLE.
KEEPING THE JUNE 12th DATE
MAYBE DIFFICULT, BUT HE WROTE IF
YOU CHANGE YOUR MIND, PLEASE
DON'T HESITATE TO CALL ME OR
WRITE.
THE PRESIDENT ADDING I FELT A
WONDERFUL DIALOGUE WAS BUILDING
UP BETWEEN YOU AND ME.
A COMBINATION OF HONEY AND
VINEGAR TO ATTRACT THE BEE.
President: IF AND WHEN KIM KIM K
President: IF AND WHEN KIM KIM M
JONG UN -- I AM WAITING.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SENT THE
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF AND AN
ADVANCE TEAM TO SINGAPORE TO
MEET WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
DELEGATION TO NAIL DOWN PLANS